well I'm joined Now by Rupert Everett is
starring in the play a voyage around my
father Rupert great to see you
great to see you although it's quite
ghostly because I can't see you how are
you you're looking a little like Michael
Corleone in uh Godfather 2 with that
backdrop well I'm I'm covered in wigs
you might not believe this but I'm
actually wearing two wigs at the moment
really
no look I read I want to get you off
because I don't really interview I read
an interview you did with the times this
week that made me laugh out loud so many
times I ordered the team to book you as
a matter of urgency my first question is
when you read back interviews like that
do you chuckle like the rest of us are
you slightly horrified at the stuff you
come out with are you proud of it how do
you feel
um well I think nowadays I'm absolutely
terrified every time I have to do an
interview I come out in hives and I
never ever dare read them because it's
so scary you know you can't really you
have to be so careful what you say
um you can't really uh just chat and and
have a lively discussion with someone
you always have to watch what you're
saying and I find that very uh it's very
alien to me because I've spent my life
really I'm having a lovely time with
journalists and chatting about
everything and now that's that's uh
that's a little more complicated it is
and it's a great tragedy that's why I
did this show actually called uncensored
you can say whatever you like
um Talking and saying what the hell you
like it is a tragedy well yeah I did
notice at the end I did Everett's best
put Downs as a little breakout and and I
I appear in your best ever put Downs uh
you call Madonna an old whiny barmaid
you said Michael Jackson looked like a
character from Shrek and Piers Morgan
was hung like a budgie
hmm
we've been through this business
I've admitted you had no evidence for
that slur
no one needs evidence anymore not these
days exactly exactly
um let's talk about a few things on the
news because there's a lot going on
which I immediately thought of you when
I hear these stories notably uh the
fiori over Bradley Cooper playing
Leonard Bernstein in the biopic Maestro
the the great uh musical impresario and
now the fiori is simply that Bradley
Cooper is not himself Jewish or gay like
Bernstein why should that be a problem
why is there a Ferrari about this
appears I don't know for me it's
ridiculous I think acting is about
acting you don't have to be Jewish to
play Jewish you don't have to be gay to
play gay I think the thing that's
irritating for gay actors is that quite
often we don't get the chance to play
straight but that doesn't mean to say
that straight actors shouldn't be
playing gay I felt deeply moved by
um for example Behind the Candelabra
with Matt Damon and um I I felt moved by
the effort and the detail with which
they attacked their roles
um I love of course seeing uh gay actors
playing gay Parts I'd like to see more
gay actors playing straight Parts I
don't see uh that this fear that of
cultural appropriation it doesn't make
sense that's what acting is about
essentially yeah I mean I've been saying
this for for a long time now the whole
purpose of acting is to play something
you're not right so if the new rules are
that you can only play
roles which are literally you that's not
acting to me
well it is acting there's one side of
acting that is like that after all the
big movie stars uh you know of the past
anyway they more or less did play
themselves but that's not the only side
of acting there's lots of other things
in acting and particularly uh in the
theater and particularly in independent
cinema you want to see people doing
different things it's exciting it's fun
you want to follow someone's career from
playing I don't know from to
Romeo or whatever it is
um but but to say that you can only only
a gay person can play a gay person or
only a straight person can play a
straight person is wrong after all human
beings aren't essentially that different
from one another
group what was interesting to me was
Leonard Bernstein's own family came out
and said was certain our dad would have
been fine with it so there's no offense
by the people who everyone is getting
offended on behalf of in other words the
Leonard Bernstein family they don't have
a problem with this the the the the the
Scandal if you like has been completely
generated in the normal way by virtue
signalers hitting social media and
saying I'm outraged
no absolutely in a very small number of
people as well most people I've talked
to have really enjoyed the movie and
loved him and I think he's an incredible
actor and it's a great shame that the
movie gets tarnished in a time when we
really need movies to to press on and do
well yeah I completely agree I mean it
doesn't help to me for this to be when
people like Michael Sheen the actor said
he doesn't like non-welsh actors playing
Welsh characters he finds it hard to
accept given that he himself has played
Tony Blair David Frost very successfully
but they last time I checked weren't
Welsh
right well I just think you know
Everyone's entitled to their opinion
after all but I don't agree about that
myself
you touched on earlier people say or do
things and bang uh they get canceled and
so on
um you appeared in a movie uh with
Russell Brown what do you make of this
scandal in particular not necessarily
him or the allegations against him but
about the place we Now now find
ourselves in a society when allegations
get made but before due process has been
seen to be done
people get obliterated is that is that
right and proper
well I think it's there's two things to
say here obviously one one of the things
we have to always preempt this
conversation with this rape is a
horrible terrible thing and we're all
against it however uh you know I would
like to quote to you the Magna Carta
which says no free man is to be arrested
or imprisoned or outlawed or exiled or
in any way ruined nor will we go against
him or send against him except by the
lawful Judgment of his peers or by the
law of the land and that is what we
should keep two peers I I agree I agree
with that and I think it's really
important and it doesn't matter what you
think of Russell Brand when you're in in
uh some trillions with him I think what
were your Recollections of him as a
bloke when you were with him
uh well there were a lot of beautiful
women on Saint trinians and there was
never any uh Scandal to do with Russell
Brandt and I'm quite a tittle tattle and
I've always got my ear to the wall so
I'm pretty sure that there wasn't uh he
kept himself to himself uh he ate funny
food you know he's one of those he's a
strange character he's one of those
people who can swap heroin for bird food
you know in the flash of an eye and uh
and and I don't agree with actually more
or less anything he says and I do think
he's a character rather like Rob spear
you know who had to wait for to meet the
king for two weeks and then suddenly
became revolutionary through his own
kind of thwarted uh bitter pride and I
do feel that Russell Brand has an Envy
of wealth which is quite uh weird but
um he behaved perfectly well very well
on um
um on St trinians you know we had to
concentrate on acting most of the time
yeah
you say in the times interview another
thing which really uh struck me I come
from a Survivor generation rather than
the victim generation you know I love
that because that is really that's what
I think which is that if you go through
enough stuff in previous generations you
tend to it tends to toughen you up it
hardens you up but what what people
didn't have time for or an inclination
was to wallow in their own victimhood
but we've now moved to a place where not
only are people doing that in large
numbers but they're kind of monetizing
it they're becoming famous off the back
of it it's almost like being a victim
now something to be praised which I find
a very disconcerting way for society to
go
I I agree with you I think uh you know
in in my youth uh you know it was it was
quite a rough and tumble world and uh
you had to uh you had to be very
Vigilant and aware of what was going on
and you had to fight your corner you
know certainly in show business as uh as
the actor Edmund Keane said uh you know
theater is not made for those who bleed
easily uh you have to be tough in this
business there's no point going into it
if you're going to wilt at the first
fence and uh and I think that gives you
a resilience and that resilience is is a
great thing for your whole life really I
think um
to play to one's own weakness is uh is
is often just not
not a good good idea really because it
just makes you weaker and weaker and
weaker
you said that you were excited by the
thought of dying
explain yourself I am why would that
excite you well I think
I think well it's the final frontier uh
it's uh it's got so much to do with it
to do with you know is does anything
happen afterwards do you just disappear
do you join uh The Ether uh I my
favorite story of death actually is in
The Little Mermaid as written by Hans
Christian Anderson not the the Disney
cartoon when The Little Mermaid throws
herself off the side of the boat because
the prince is never going to love her
and she becomes as she lands in the sea
she becomes a bit of phosphorus
phosphorescence on the top of a wave and
then she becomes a bubble and then she
realizes that that bubble is just going
to go around the earth for thousands of
years and then turn into nothing and um
it was I think it's a very uh beautiful
idea and um I think death is uh you know
it's it's a it's an exciting front here
what do you think well not illness and
pain uh I don't I think the thing about
pain and illness is is horrible uh of
course and uh and and and being
frightened is always horrible but the
actual idea of death I think is um
exciting and I think what happens to you
for myself I believe that there is
an energy which is the energy that built
or constructed the big bang and I think
it's passing through all of us and I
think we are that energy and somehow
that energy keeps moving it's very
difficult for us to grasp because we're
so hung up on our own identity of me
Rupert and I will never change my spots
etc etc our characters are very very
superficial uh parts of us they're just
a kind of carapace I think and inside
that is the space of whatever you want
to call it God or the universe or or the
flow of energy that is you know
constantly moving outwards and expanding
that's right and if you could choose the
manner of your death what would you
choose
uh the manner of my death well obviously
it would be very nice uh either to die
in my sleep or for someone to like just
shoot you in the back of the head uh
while you're going to Safeways
anymore waitrose I will make myself
available as revenge for the budgie
comment
anyway listen Piers what I came on to
talk about by the way was my place
and it's oh and it's on tour yeah and
we're in bath now we're going to
Chichester uh it's a very funny Play
It's like Chekov but it's also like
Dad's Army it's written by John Mortimer
a great writer eloquent peers and
eloquence I think is one of the things
that's beginning to be missing yeah I
went out for tea this afternoon and the
girl at the table next to me is going
like like like like like I mean it just
never stopped and we're letting our
language disappear and language which
we've made over two million years and it
hasn't been easy and we should cherish
it and this play does I look forward to
that and I endorse everything you just
said about languages it's a bug bearer
of mine in fact we actually have a lot
of things that we agree about Ruby it
may be our old Advanced age but we've
reached a place where I think we agree
with more things than we disagree
I agree I do agree with you on many
things peers it's great to have you on
Facebook in a sense so thank you very
much everybody particularly on your
about your wife who I'm very fond of
yeah and she's very fond of you a little
too fond for my liking but there we are
good to talk to you anyway is that it
thank you very much peers see you next
time all the best Robert welcome anytime
thank you very much thanks a lot all the
best lots of love bye